alles offen weil es nicht
dass ich wussten alle freunde wir sind
hier heute weil diana zuhause hallo die
habe und fast könnte das sind wir dann
die studie zur verfügung steht gewann
grad im rossmann und zwar haben diana
und ich etwas befriedigt eingekauft das
packt rallye auf seinem kanal city und
yaya damit was für mich eingekauft was
ich jetzt gleich auspacken werde
ich habe noch was medianer aufgekauft
bastian
denken
ich habe hier ein
habt ihr das zauber der panflöte ich
zeige dass man hier ein zauber der
panflöte
instrumente zero mein gott das ist ja
sogar drauf singen ich hab da auch so
und vor darauf gespart sagt
ich liebe es ist echt also
unfassbar
ja dann haben wir noch diese kleine
dieses kleine technische gekommen weil
ich bin eine person die immer wenn ich
irgendwie feiern wir oder so verliere
ich das immer sehr schnell ein
vorzeigeverein ist euch und ich weiß so
was wie kleiner kleiner klappt super
ding hatte ich mir schon immer auch für
93 vorfeld komplett empfehlen sie ja
dann haben wir hier einen zuwachs
von heidi klum
haben wir das alle und vor allem es
reicht für bis zu 60 anwendungen mein
gott ist das wie weiter haben hier wie
sich prinzessin und das habt ihr mir
gekauft damit ich spaß dann warten hat
dann habe ich
ja
ich möchte mir diese teile die man
meinen kaffee dabei bekommt im
italienischen kaffee ist oder wenn das
grüne monster
dann essen wir
ja dann haben wir als nächstes jahr eine
tüte und
es ist sogar eine batterie dabei ja
freude dass auch mal wieso habt ihr so
ein kosmetik was sie damit gebracht
du siehst ich denke
da haben wir als nächstes
eine eine belastung für alle situationen
alles super ist
kaputt
da mach ich das erstmal hole das heißt
dass sie direkt hat mit können diese
also das ist eine qualität ihre mühe
gegeben dass wir ja gut vorne dann habe
ich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal neues
armband danke dafür
ich mache mir da völlig in der
zwischenzeit packe ich aber das nächste
aus und zwar
was ist
so cool aussehen können
so hat man es vielleicht nochmal drüber
machen
ja ich freue
mich aber noch so viele übrig die kann
ja dann noch der alles benutzen
die basic danke also das ist genau das
was ich mir schon großmann kaufen wollte
dann haben wir die nächste sache ein
medicus
shampoos und dusche
ein wort
wunderschön dann haben wir ein
volk dafür benutzt man das wenn die haut
heißt
danke ich auf jeden fall bei euch beiden
dass ihr heute unfassbar viele gedanken
gemacht hat was ich gebrauchen können zu
meinem leben auch hier mit den keks
so das ist auch immer wichtig finde dass
man eben die gut aussieht also die erst
gerade aus wir haben halt hier
irgendwann wissen was nach der totalen
wir uns natürlich weit gekommen aber
naja freude so ist das wenn man mal ein
ohr lauf nimmt
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen die us kanal
wo wir dianas tasche ausgepackt ist in
der beschreibung verlinkt freddys kanals
in der beschreibung verlinken